it's 2700 BC you're living in ancient
Mesopotamia you've had a great harvest
you've just come home from celebrating
some resources with your friends and are
contemplating the meaning of life and
why the hell you're even here when
something amazing happens the first book
just drops the Epic of Gilgamesh changes
your life it really explains the
importance of making your bed in the
morning and creating productive and
sustainable habits and for thousands of
years to come the brightest human rights
will can book of the book on the
importance of Leverage and Outsourcing
and just why you're such a badass
course they don't while we've already
struggled with the same issues
self-doubt anxieties depression
procrastination we used to approach
these things a lot better art poetry
theater music used to approach these
things in a way that had depth that had
passion and eventually was much more
effective than the dry self-help books
that we have today now despite the title
of this video I do just want to say that
everyone is free to read whatever the
hell makes them happy and I myself very
often actually read self-help books but
the reason I'm making this video is
because quite often I get told off for
almost wasting my time reading fictional
books when actually I really strongly
believe that when it comes to self-help
or self-improvement or just living a
better life nothing and absolutely
nothing tops a good fictional book a
post write every person is capable of
transforming a good fictional book into
their own personal non-fiction self-help
book which will be a thousand times more
effective than any other self-help book
out there which is already written as of
today I wanted to break down why I think
we should all be doing this and how to
do it exactly let's get straight into it
we crawl out of the womb surprised to be
alone is a beautiful quote by Adrian
Mayor Brown which I think really
captures this sense of human existence
which is very often quite alone
disconnected and craving a connection
with someone else however she goes on to
say that nothing is truly random the
universe has its favorites and it
repeats them again and again in the same
way that our fingerprints are the same
shape as galaxies this repeating nature
this almost fractal nature of existence
doesn't just happen with physical things
but also happens with our experiences
and I think that this is where the
self-help genre really comes in because
on one hand we have this deep sense of
Disconnect and loneliness and on the
other hand we have the realization that
other people have been through this too
I am connected I am part of something
and that other people who have lived in
the past have gone through this and
other people perhaps who are living now
are going through the same things I
think that this is a journey and a task
that we should all do individually and
we are kind of underselling it by
Outsourcing it to other people who have
made these connections and these rules
self-help books just crassly tell us
things and give us information but
literature and art do is give us the
elements to come to these conclusions
ourselves and I think that this
realization is just so much more
powerful and effective and time enough
for Love at one point the protagonist
says of the few things I've learned is
that humans hardly learn from the
experience of others they learn when
they do which isn't often on their own
the hard way so it's not only that we
learn by experience is that we only
sometimes learn from from our own
experience and we might have realized
this ourselves for me for example very
often I don't do things or I can't do
things not because I don't have the
knowledge but because I can't apply that
knowledge because it was never mine it
was just given to me from someone else
so I think we're possible obviously the
best thing to do is to be mindful of
things are happening in our own personal
lives and learning from them but the
second best thing to do is to gain
conclusions ourselves from the things
that other people around us are doing I
think that there is just something so
much deeper in being able to witness
someone's life in full and being able to
observe it and the lessons that you can
get from the things that they are going
through are much more effective than a
lecture that they can give you I think
that we are hardwired to enjoy
storytelling in a way that is much more
effective than just like lessons and
things being told for example if someone
was to read a fictional biography of
Jordan Peterson I would would get so
much more lessons for living my life
than listening to his lectures or the
books that he's explicitly written
telling me to do things as Jeanette
witherson said I am Telling You stories
trust me so I really think that we are
hardwired to gain much more and to be
able to interpret stories better than we
give ourselves credit for furthermore a
very important reason I prefer
literature is captured by Donald Donahue
who says the poor have been doubly
impoverished by the ugliness that
surrounds them and this really captures
the fact that living in urban areas we
are surrounded by lack of beauty lack of
Nature and just ugliness and grayness
around us I think that we are very much
hardwired to enjoy beautiful things for
example if we look at a waterfall or if
we look at the Earth from a mountain or
if we hear a beautiful piece of
classical music or if we hear and read
something beautiful in literature we
feel something I'm making everything
around us so gray and mass produced and
not unique I think we have robbed
ourselves of so much pleasure from our
daily lives and I feel that self-help
books are just a continuation of this
damage that is being done we've gone
from mythology poetry literature and
arts to just dry productivity advice and
the thing is the these Original Stories
were actually giving the exact same
advice they didn't put just taking so
much more care in the experience of the
person who is reading them and absorbing
them and not being completely explicit
with them but I think we've just
stripped that all down and we've just
cut down to the chase which we've done
with so many things around us and I
think natural beauty is just so
essential to experiencing a good life
for example Pascal said you should
always keep something beautiful in mind
because it is the power of that which
will help us endure what can sometimes
be the bleakness of our existence and
this I feel is so underrated and because
literature is I think a lot closer to
this beauty and this nature it takes
inspiration from things that are around
us and tries to replicate in a verbal
form things that we experience in the
world I think it really captures what is
really natural Jeanette witherson said
very few people ever manage what nature
manages without effort and mostly
without fail we don't know who we are or
how to function much less how to bloom
blind nature Homo sapiens who's kidding
whom taking inspiration from nature and
anchoring our self-help and productivity
advice to messages which are beautiful
within themselves that care for the form
of of delivery make the experience of
reading just so much more pleasurable
and effective I think we're naturally
curious about the worlds and stories and
we should incorporate these in the
messages that we are trying to give John
and Donahue also said it's strange to be
here the mystery never leaves you alone
so now let's go to specifically how I
transform literature books into
self-help books and the very first thing
that I will do is focus on the
characters within themselves and this
can be a main character a protagonist or
a side character and I'm really seeing
them not as someone who's just doing
things so not as someone who is taking
actions to drive the story forward but
more someone to whom things are done
someone who is kind of being changed and
being affected by things that people say
around them by things that happen to
them by things that they are thinking
themselves and therefore I'm trying to
find cause and effect where I can see it
and try to interpret and come up for
rules for what I see so to get very
specific example into the lighthouse
Virginia Woolf describes the interaction
between a mother and a guest male guest
in her house where she says but
afterwards they got on perfectly and she
made herself out even more ignorant than
she was because he liked telling her
that she was a fool now this is a very
powerful paragraph and especially in
contacts you can really see many layers
of human interaction here and of course
the most obvious one seems to be around
the gender roles so a woman making
herself feel foolish so that a man can
feel comfortable and like her more so we
can analyze this on this level also we
can go in deeper and strip it off the
gender roles themselves and kind of see
this human interaction and this power
play and what can make someone who
values power feel better about you or
feel better about themselves and what
this interaction is so in the sentence
alone even ignoring the rest of the
story there is so much analysis that we
are free to do and insert ourselves on
how human nature works and how
interactions work there's no need to
read a whole book on like making friends
and influencing people and all that kind
of stuff that gives these kind of raw
lines just with this line we can go back
and see how she's been interacting so
far how the relationships have happened
and we can analyze a lot better and come
up with a lot more rules for better
understanding friendship and love and
human interaction Dynamics the second
way that I love to analyze fictional
books is to see how the characters just
are and what I mean by this is that very
often I tend to think of what I should
be what I should do what decisions I
should make and very rarely do I
actually think of how to be how do I
exist what is my daily emotion
throughout the day and what is my
experience of this life this I do not
pay a lot of attention to so I probably
should but I've tried to do this in
books themselves and I kind of try to
see this how layer and observing the
characters in the book and seeing how
are they existing how do they view life
and what is their primary emotional
state and how are they maintaining this
or going away from this to go back to
the lighthouse at one point about the
mother it said she had done the usual
trick been nice she would never know him
he would never know her and this is a
specific Rule and experience for how to
live your life and it kind of shows that
balance of how much you open up to
someone and what sort of connection you
can have at different levels and this
can be seen as a way of living and how
much to open up about yourself with the
people who are around you and what level
of interaction you can achieve with this
and this also becomes an anchor so every
time that there is a rule it kind of
stays in my mind and then I go
retrospectively and see what the
character has done so far and how this
has informed her decision making and
also take this role in the future for
the book and kind of see all the other
decisions that she makes in light of
this and thirdly for this video
literature books are turned into
self-help books by looking at the change
and the progression of the characters
very often I will pick up a theme for a
character and then I will see what sorts
of things they can inform in this
direction for example time enough for
love there's a character who can teach
us how to live a comfortable life with
minimal effort and I came up with I
think a seven or eight points of how to
do this thing like for example there
were things like oh have your managers
at work observe you when you're doing
hard work and things like this a very
kind of like funny self-helpy tips that
could be taken from the book in this way
and on the other hand I found that one
of the main themes into the lighthouse
was how to deal with depression and how
to overcome with depression in your
family and there were a few rules again
I don't have to agree with all of them
there are things like have a baby or
witness pure joy around you or have
someone who is like toxically positive
be surrounded by them that can lessen
your anxiety so there are a lot of tips
I think that the authors were subtly
given within the story so every time
that I have this theme in mind I will
try to approach the book with it and on
the back of the book so on the back
cover or on the last few pages that
don't have any writing on them I will
kind of write these rules one by one and
depending on the book sometimes there'll
be three rules or ten rules or 20 or 30
depending on what I want to gain from it
so in this way by the end of the
fictional little story I've had a really
fun experience of kind of seeing Beauty
seeing a storyline seeing what happens
to the characters feeling connected to
people in the world but also some really
strong messages that I can take forward
into my life so as I said earlier I do
still read quite a lot of non-fiction
books and self-help books and I do
summarize them up on my website which
you are free to see if you want to kind
of see my interpretations or how I
approach them but also most importantly
this also highlights the value of having
a personal website even if you're not in
the stage of your life where you want to
build something like this kind of
investing in it and having the domain
for the future I find can be super
helpful so I'm very grateful to Hoover
who are very kindly sponsoring this
video it cost me under 10 pounds to get
one that I needed and most importantly
even if you don't want to do this for
yourself I find that they make a
brilliant gift to give someone that you
care for just buy them a website for a
project or a name of something that you
know that they like and gifting it to
them to kind of inspire them along the
Journey of getting started with this
thing I feel is such a wholesome easy
and thoughtful gift so there will be a
link in my description for a discount on
Hoover if you want to fancy doing
something like that right now if not no
worries thank you so much for spending
this time with me I hope you have a
wonderful rest every day because
yourself on others and don't believe
everything you think thanks bye